being led up in the office to apply
water to corporate both of our ownership
and leverage taking protectors that out
those average
this house is fun to work while I've got
you you do community some changes to my
youtube channel I'm going to activate on
ads not unfortunately but I'm activating
on ads I want to let you guys know
because when we have music that kicks in
ads we can't control the type of ads
that play you know the counts that run
ads on us so we're going to turn them on
for control of what's on there we'll buy
some new clothes do specific so that's
what's going on just an incredibly
amazing conversation I went to Dallas
today back and forth I've got to give
you some of the footage soft shadows to
focus
[Music]
your car service doesn't show up anyway
when to Dallas for client said back but
when I landed had an incredible
conversation with the team about YouTube
shits about to get real interesting it's
super crazy like I looked at my schedule
like oh I landed like 8:15 I'm like I
should do something yeah and I've been
trying to want to do more wine events
and getting kind of thought leaders
friends together to be good there's some
good people right here let me live for
Teague last one I should come here peer
outreach to come here every day yeah but
I accidentally moved twice you know
Vayner and you visit us when we're on
23rd we had already moved no we met
right I remember
so we were on 23rd and park so I would
just shoots right here I live on the
Upper East Side it was basically in
between so I came all the time right but
now that I'm in Hudson yard it just you
know yeah not big and the travel has
been like hardcore so right family good
so I actually went to inbox zero in 2000
from 2006 to 2009
I would go to inbox zero and went to
sleep at three or four o'clock in
morning every night you know you don't
even talk about that directly I used to
go to Wine Library at 11:00 a.m. for a
cup for like a year because I was like
4:30 I'd be like I would go to inbox
zero every night nobody ever writes for
me it's always when it's amaze me like
nobody ever believes me I always have to
like on snapchat lately I've been doing
a lot of replying and every time not you
and then I just like make a quick little
like video I'm okay and like holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I need to open the red wine
gimme one second yeah welcome inspires
me
I appreciate them in person so happy
I look sick I think we should say so
obviously some of you know I grew up in
the wine world and wine is fun oh she
had 10 p.m. at night on a Tuesday if
that's why [ __ ] New York cities of
death and you just want to start
gathering more friends in business more
often talk about the State of the Union
about what's going on with Netflix and
Facebook and Amazon buying Whole Foods
we'll get brought up tonight just like
trying to do more of these power dinners
where we drink good wine so I get to use
that as a framework to get eight or nine
interesting people together that I
interact with in business to shoot the
[ __ ] about the State of the Union of the
business tech marketing media world and
so I think I'm gonna try to do more of
these and hopefully we'll cover them I
think it's cool content cool well I'm
super pumped you guys are here I I have
been really like on a mission to like
start up a wine series so here's my
concept I want a couple rules number one
one conversation so we're going to be in
one joint conversation number two we'll
talk a little bit about the wines and
like I really want to go through that
and but it's not serious by any stretch
I think mine's way too serious and I
just want to enjoy it if we can we just
want to be trio for now so like whatever
is there's like AB and and and number
three introduce yourselves we are living
through one of the great generational
shift of the end consumers attention
that's what Boehner is all about I'm
feeling it if you know who kid by the
name of Jake Paula's he's a personality
a Viner now his brother was a very
famous fine he's picked up two million
two million YouTube subscribers in the
last 30 days he's making miss dollars a
month in Adwords
making videos on YouTube and the
pre-rolls he's doing MTV be ready Rock
he's doing MTV he's doing always doing
jackass
that's ways it who anyway
punch I mean for all of us all our
aspirations the people we you know we
represent what work we're trying to do
as a media company the brands were
working for what we're trying to do as
an agency wait to hear what my man here
is up to attention arbitrage shifted the
new rules are substantial I can't in the
future Jeremy give you dinner yes
understood got it got it yeah time but
yeah I don't know I so when things
shipped it's a same way it was so funny
he said something really interesting to
me he said his first reaction was
Walmart has a run for its money and I
while he was talking I was kind of
looking whatever but I was like wow for
five years minimally I had never crossed
my mind
that Amazon wouldn't destroy Walmart and
I've got tons of old videos where I say
it he said that because when he looks at
his companies this word things selling
you know this they're still selling in
those places it's the same thing as text
text is winning cuz Texas right this
minute like the second we're still in
the era of text but the behavior is
starting a voice so for example one of
my great fears literally this is a true
thing was texting and drive there's no
amount of alcohol that's more dangerous
than texting and driving like it's crazy
how dangerous texting and driving is
literally when I started getting bullish
on voice about a year and a half ago I'm
like all good my kids will never live in
a world where they're going to tax and
drive
no no I don't know no no no no I'm
college a jewel collection it's all
about time savings so or were one
because it saves you time prime wins
because it saves you time Fresh Direct
wins could save you time I don't think
people going to talk because that's
time-consuming because we wait for each
other I think that whatever in the world
ever happens mind translation anything
we will always we will always pick
convenience over everything
I for years ago long before like Russia
and Trump I would say things in my
keynotes like we don't give a [ __ ] about
privacy and people would get really
upset and then I would say just for a
minute take a step back and think about
how much of your information you give
away every day for convenience speed so
so I believe that there are a lot of
things voice can do when you have a
completely automated AI voice
infrastructure in your home when you're
on your phone near you here we have your
phone right here if you can say Alexa or
Google or Apple what's my what is my
schedule today and the house is talking
to you it's just faster than taking your
phone hitting turning on sweat
popular and Happiness because you can
put all hey Lex
hey body made it la may la may la May
Ohio see Malone he goes with it oh but I
see alone giggles with my voice
messenger okay
hey no cries King Mike Boyd I'm gonna
give me my quick my boy story my brother
calls me his third day of college in
Psych I met a really weird duty as an
afro he's from the hood of Saint Louis
and he knows everything about rap that's
okay and I said and he knows who's gonna
be cool and rapped next I'm like well
challenge him to tell you who it's gonna
be cool Mike Boyd goes in his room
spends like a full day on MySpace comes
out of the room and tells AJ some rapper
two and a half years later me and AJ go
into a pre-season Jets game on route 70
on New Jersey Turnpike we're listening
to hot 97 and AJ freaks out and tells me
to pull over the car I felt like I had a
flat tire and he goes do you remember
this story from two years ago that I
called you and said I met my friend and
he's a friend he's gonna be my friend
and he's like yeah he goes the guy that
he told me about is the song that we're
listening to right now on the radio and
that was Soulja Boy I have no idea how
much your hip-hop Mahlum knowledge is
but like Boyd knows everything about rap
I'll see a little bit yeah
Instagram is the incumbent leader my
Instagram following has gone from
400,000 to 2.1 million in the last 7
months I've had unbuilt getting serious
about it going on vacation this is true
and d-roc will tell you I went on
vacation with my wife we went off the
grid for 5 days but I can't go
completely off the grid so I was just
listening to Spotify muse new this is
actually amazing all I did for 6 days
where did I go this time and I said guys
I think I should take Instagram way more
seriously I'll get back to you like
tomorrow after I dissect it so I spent
like a whole day you know when you have
like 15 hours I just I did my things
dissected it and literally the next day
I started the process of like the
strategy of how to build myself
basically becoming native what's
amazingly ironic about me telling you
this right now is literally as durak
will tell you right now right before I
walked in here today I told my team on a
call like literally as I walked in here
as soon as I walked in to see you guys I
got a call with six of my five my team
members and said this ain't I've not
done it since so we're here nine months
later I had the same conversation my
team today about YouTube it all clicked
we weren't feeling good we couldn't we
were like like that I'm away in August
and it's a new thing for us like oh it's
real good I feel very confident in excel
class it speaks to getting off your grid
I don't I never as innovative I'm
operating I'm operating all the other
time so you know I'm a very big fan of
like getting out of your normal element
I never do that other than vacation time
it's cool class clown spit facts crammed
in this calf gantry whatever also up in
that sochi smackdown wrestle it
references for my
eggless now I use my ADHD Felicia
benefice rappers consisted of the ROM in
the ritual lucky that I'm from the East
Coast so with the pitch perfect with
precision thought it was gorgeous no
finical sacrificing soldiers or soccer
move from West Ritter's do sighs thank
you so fun to spend time again big on
the past issues it grew from a flow
you'd be smoother than the best
recruiting
hey I said Kumar sir here you must feel
like just email I started I had a
private of that case the fire our
premiere challenge writer said you can
create I know
alright so how you read so we got a big
group will vote will consolidate our we
put our to clean us here how do you know
these guys I just met them foot around
all the right people around here say one
thing they're doing and I thought you
really liked it
a lot of times my kid I believe I
believe in that theory the most on the
right way I mean we've you successfully
your social media Stephanie hitting up
social media influence a girl strategy a
couple hundred bucks then repost the
issue is I'm glad you guys are doing it
there's no waiting yeah that's the best
part like my face is bright but it's
still going to come down to the artists
being good like if you suck [ __ ] and
everybody hears you
you just lost quicker and we're gonna
move on right you just lost quickly
really like it's not just about exposure
after that graduation was upon me at the
prom mammy 7,000,000 finish saucy life
skin mommy's a penis curry of having
khakis
so if you really realize why pop daddy's
real big besides getting a bunch of
artists that blew up he hacked TRL when
every teenager watched TRL where's the
attention how do you produce for it why
I think artists need to put out a song
on SoundCloud Spotify every week because
there's a tension there and you're one
[ __ ] song away from your whole life
being different like that crazy
sacrificing soldiers a sucker move from
what it is do we keeping the cultural
movement from our knees or just hoop
with kids in the game matter be asking
what the adults are doing if you need a
deposit fig on the best shoes and grew
from Buffalo you'd be smoother than the
best book rule a you caught it it's just
on patient because I really want to be a
mobile and being a mogul doesn't mean
Lamborghinis off I'll save that two
hundred thousand and invested you keep
your being a mogul isn't putting [ __ ]
a stack of cash to your face
we're having a baby giraffe in the end
that's why
as long as you gets in to the place
where he feels good so for me I hit good
at a hundred thousand a year I was good
like I said you know everybody good
right yeah you got to make sure he feels
good
whatever you need anyway whether it's a
million or a dollar
you got to get that you got to figure
out who all of you the whole family
you've got to get to that place where
they're good and then you can win
because if you're holding off public
look when you're young like let's call
this whole alpha world everybody's
trading so first of all why does
everybody throw Lamborghinis and cash
under bed they're insecure dudes that
need to use that to get girls so now you
got to break it down make sure everybody
here is good they've got what they need
and it's look if they need if they need
a nice watch because MIT listen by the
way maybe when you were eight and you
like maybe your uncle wore a nice like
you can't judge what everybody needs
baby think like you judge you just try
to get to the minimum then everybody
gets good and then you win that's why I
win my good was a hundred thousand my
lifestyle
now now my lifestyle today far exceeds
it but if I had to go backwards like
rock rocky six I'm good at a hundred
thousand
so you got us a note you got to get
everybody you guys should be real with
yourself as a unit like and nobody
should be embarrassed everybody needs to
make everybody feel comfortable to be
like what gets you good because once
you're good and I'm going to come listen
people come from money people don't come
for money everybody's cover [ __ ]
whatever's good get everybody to good
because that's when you go on the
offense I said come on son you must be
off Sycamore sir you must be off real
quick and I want everybody here is
because it's our hope you guys make
decisions the nine people that [ __ ] you
don't offset the one person that comes
through that's why it's a good bet
that's what people get I don't give up I
can do everything for you and you could
forget my name and it would unfazed me
that's the biggest piece that's the part
that's the part you better remember
that's the singular piece that makes the
whole thing go around not having
expectations a family live that person
[ __ ] you you don't give a [ __ ] that's
the game listen I got to run but
anything I can do for you guys I mean
the biggest conversations available very
mature I'd love to help if I can
of course my mentor taught me so that
goes
you think you're walking out I want to
walk out get your [ __ ] ass back I'd
like to walk out I'm getting at least a
12 minute okay so here's the debate what
we're talking give me your opinion oh
yeah
Becca yeah but the dancers call you in
here
they wanted so they wouldn't this they
care about so I'm letting you do it the
business cares let me tell you who cares
let me go get garrus he gets put on here
he shares it with his 85 buddies all 40
[ __ ] [ __ ] guys from Wall Street
come in and be like this got it who
cares of the 40 people that [ __ ] pay
the bills here this [ __ ] and
pains like some [ __ ] comments not at
you know what makes me really good is i
do close yeah yeah got it
comrades here he's been sharing
everything oh go ahead visit a joke that
a correct here's what I would say the
count you're young and the counts young
don't overthink [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
if that gets 97 like so that gets 40,000
views cash in your row you're not
managing Nike that's a one story unit
restaurant you've got an entrepreneur
whose [ __ ] line we believes take
advantage [ __ ] put out four posts a
day and take [ __ ] boomerangs [ __ ]
like got it that's why numbness matters
if you're wrong
feel cotton while your doctor volume Geo
file you how do you think I [ __ ]
invention 62nd club work other shift got
forgotten I've have a million of them we
[ __ ] hot [ __ ] all in time in his work
everybody remembers every month nobody
remembers that Michael Jordan played
baseball because he fell back exactly
like nobody remember you know like like
the same people that remember Frank
Sinatra exactly like the bottom line is
nobody remembers your losses I get it
I love you I'll keep you updated on the
NBA have a book maybe of course of
course you designed for me a hundred
thousand percent yeah what's his name
James uh Maurice Maurice appreciate my
pleasure nice enter see you have a good
night
I could I dream on thanks for playing
alone oh man
take care of stuff thank you
[Music]
well actually was fire I see that I
showed this duffel project that we gotta
listen to a man played a nice little bro
yeah we are